[Music]
and good morning everyone um my name is
Ian Vincent says from PI date London I'm
so proud of the community that we built
there that I'm still wearing the t-shirt
from our conference last month if you
ever come to London you're very welcome
to come and join our monthly meetups and
the annual conference that we run so
here I'm going to be talking about
creating correct and capable classifiers
I like my alliterative titles and I
particularly like debugging my machine
learning and understanding why it's
doing what it says it's doing such that
I can explain it to other people and
such that I can be confident myself so
I'm an engineering data scientist unlike
a lot of data scientists I don't have a
PhD I didn't go down the formal academic
route I had a master's degree and then
joined the startup world with dreams of
glory avarice and early retirement and
of course it went way before it all went
wrong and I thought I shouldn't do a PhD
and then nerve would joined another
company then started my own company it
kind of goes around and so I've been an
engineering data scientist for fifteen
years and kind of making it all up as I
go along and as a result of that ii
ended up writing a book on
high-performance computing with a
variety several years ago with a u.s.
colleague misha Gorelick of bitly at the
time and along the way I've built
several communities and the one that I'm
really proud of is this PI data London
we're like seven and a half thousand
members in London now and it makes it
the largest PI date on the planet which
I'm super happy about and I'm
particularly happy that last week the PI
data group globally we got to 100
meetups around the planet so our PI data
community is it's not just like a bit
globe but it's probably global I guess
three digits now we know this is great
and we got to keep growing
that's why we work with all sorts of
companies both small startups and larger
organizations Mitsubishi finance bank
channel four key B is an insurance
company I'm working most at the moment
introducing machine learning and then
using these kind of techniques on the
ground to help communicate this work
colleagues before I get into the talk
there's a point that I've been
increasingly making over the last
several years and many people who come
to these conferences see them as
commercial events and they forget that
they are mostly volunteer driven so the
non focus group behind this puts in
tireless work around the world to
promote pie data all the PI data
organizers they're typically all
volunteers in London I've got a 13
strong volunteer group three chairs for
the conference this year all volunteers
I've been volunteering for five years
been building this sort up everyone here
in Amsterdam is a volunteer so if you're
not used to going up to volunteers and
saying thank you
today is a brilliant time for that you
just have to go up find a speaker or we
need to volunteer organizers and just
say thank you that's a lovely thing to
do to say thank you for the volunteering
work they're doing to bring us this
conference um even better you can buy
them a beer or some cake or a cup of
coffee but just just say thank you it
makes the world a better place and it
recognizes that everyone running these
events are not paid that will volunteers
um back in London I forgot to take a
photograph of my audience I love taking
photographs photographs of audiences um
I would like to take a photograph now
given gdpr
and personally identifiable information
I've read up this morning thanks to
Michelle on the the Wikimedia Commons
rule interpretation for the Dutch laws I
believe I can take your photograph but I
don't know so I'm gonna say if anyone
objects I won't take a photograph does
anyone object and it's totally cool if
mmm I'm not going to ask for explicit
consent I'm just gonna save anyone
objects I won't do it cuz that's like a
common politeness thing and if not no
bullet in that case then please PLEASE
smile and wave at me because I just like
a happy photograph so smiling and waving
that means hands up hands up
alright that's better brilliant one of
those other one and another excellent
thank you very much yeah I don't quite
know but what the situation will be now
for taking a photograph at a private
event in a non public space because that
apparently requires explicit consent
under some interpretation so I don't
know anyway I'll be on my blog
non-commercial use it's just on my blog
right goes today we're going to talk
about getting a baseline model
machine learnings and something that we
can work from to improve against rather
than diving in with the most complex
model we might come up with which is an
approach taken by some people
visualizing errors and diagnosing areas
of problem in the machine learning model
it's a data-driven problems is it a
machine learning driven problem we'll
look at explaining decisions and I'm one
of two speakers at least talking on that
this weekend here and then if you want
more then I've got a github account to
my data science delivered project I've
been building up for several years
that's a pile of documented advice kind
of advice to myself from ten years in
the future stuff that I wished I'd known
ten years ago when I was starting this
along with a whole bunch of worked
notebooks which goes through various
examples and the examples for this talk
will be online in the next week or so so
first of all who knows pandas profiling
they don't come across this a smattering
of hands not many hands brilliant right
there's your first tool first tool for
the day so pandas profiling gives you a
really easy one line way this profile
reports to summarize the contents of a
data frame visually with some JavaScript
in your Jupiter notebook it's really
easy way of getting an overview of data
that you've got it tells you some things
about the data set here I'm using the
Kegel Titanic example because most of us
here will know Titanic talked about the
contents of the data frame so it's just
like looking at a describe and info
output from a panda's data frame but
visually and there's a few more
interesting bits one but quite like it's
the warnings it tells you things like oh
this age column has got 20% missing
value so it's kind of interesting I
could do that by hand but here I give
this automatic summary cabin has high
cardinality to 148 distinct values it
looks like a not very useful field for
doing this a machine learning and and
then some columns age imputed has very
high correlation with another column the
age column and so it would reject it
from the analysis down inside here so
maybe this gives you an early warning
about high correlations and redundant
data in your data frame it also gives
you a breakdown by tabs of some of your
or all of your columns and you get
things like safer the age column you get
a really nice histogram giving you a
distribution all of the
descriptive statistics that come out of
the info and describe functions laid out
and then four columns that are
categorical in nature like the embarked
column we also get another set of
display so these are broken out on a
bunch of tabs and then there's
correlation matrices that come out as
well so if you're starting a project
you've got new data you don't know
what's in there
put it through pandas profiling you get
a really good idea as to what's in your
data set then we're going to start so
we've done that we've got an idea about
our data now we want to think about
building a dummy classifier this first
thing that we're going to do so here I'm
going to use the psychic learned and we
classify hands up if you've used the
dummy classifier and the dummy regressor
before not enough of you at all right so
rather than starting with a complex
machine learning model diving in with HD
boost or like GBM or whatever you
whatever you think is appropriate um I
always for myself and I always recommend
going in with a very basic approach that
dummy classifier says in this case what
is the most frequent answer in the data
set and then every prediction I make
will be the most frequent answer so it's
really dumb it and if if then else rule
that makes one prediction all the time
so it's absolutely wrong a chunk of the
time and absolutely right more of the
time it's really stupid but it gives you
a baseline so you can't do any any you
shouldn't be doing any machine learning
you shouldn't be doing any worse than
this but if you don't have a baseline
you don't know so if we put the this
dummy classifier about roughly 60% of
people died on the Titanic and so 40%
survived so if we split our data X&Y
train test set on the training set we
say what is the majority of the majority
decision that people mostly die or
mostly survive or they mostly died so we
always predict that everybody dies and
then when we score on the test set we're
right about sixty percent of the time
and then wrong forty percent of the time
but at least we've got a baseline now
I've seen people dive into problems with
really complex classifiers doing loads
of work on their feature engineer and
they come up with an answer isn't it
brilliant yeah right but if we take the
output column and just take the mean of
it kind of what this is doing here we
get the same answer but you've spent two
months building a really complicated way
of predicting the mean because there's
no signal in your data and
so doing this five lines really meeting
now if we run this again on another
dataset it's one other train test split
the same decision will be made they're
saying predictions we made but the score
will be different because that test set
is varying so if we do that lots of
times we get a distribution of scores on
different test sets and even though
we're predicting one thing the majority
thing the majority outcome everybody
dies
because these train test bits are
different every time we get a different
number of people surviving and dying
between the train and test sets and this
distribution when we draw it we get some
idea of the variance in our predictions
so if you just ever take one train test
bit and you build up your model and you
get your answers and you're being very
careful your training on your train set
you're just observing the test set and
you think hey this is generalizing
really well if you then take another
train test set and you find your numbers
vary it's because of this variance in
the underlying distribution of data that
we're working from you do it many times
they like hang on a minute
I get scores from 55% to nearly 70%
that's a pretty high variance for the
dumbest to possible decision so how much
do I trust any one answer that I get
and that's a good question to bear in
mind I always suggest eyeballing the
underlying data one of the common
approaches to fixing missing data is to
impute and on the Kaggle dataset for
Titanic if you go into the form of
differences oh the age column it's
missing age data a bunch of the time so
the statistically relevant way to fix
this is to impute the median value or
the mean value or some other made-up
notion of fixing data where we've lost
the true answer and then typically
people don't graph this and so that
everybody know what this distortion what
distortion is occurring in the data if
we look at the non imputed data set we
see that there are a few very young
people that's the the most left-hand
column
most people around sort of twenty to
thirty years old and then some people go
up to about seventy years old if you
take the 200 m n a n rows and impute
them to the median you get an imputed
age of 28 and then when you stick that
back on to the data you end up with this
huge spike apparently another 20% of
your data set have suddenly become 28
years old but it's a lie right we just
made this up we made a statistical guess
about a thing and filled in this missing
data with some
I've gone back to the original records
for some of the some of the Kegel so
that the Titanic passengers and checked
if they had an imputed age of 28 what
their true age was and their true age
could be 10 or 50 it's all over the
place
so imputing without observing it's a bad
idea but least if you've drawn it you've
got an idea and it might help you to
debug things later in your project or
possibly later in the slides that we
show this morning so we've built our
baseline classifier we've got something
really simple we've done a number of
runs and we've got an idea of variants
by drawing a distribution of answers
we've eyeballed our underlying data we
fixed some of the data we've got a
pretty good idea as to what's going on
now it's time to use a more
sophisticated classifier so typically
I'll just go for a random forest if I
had lots of missing data I might use
actually boosts but random forest works
super reliably with all the tools in the
wider scikit-learn
ecosystem so we train up a bunch of
results on train test splits here I'm
using the repeated k-fold
cross-validation so that does something
padded five fold cross validation
repeated 20 times I guess so I got a
hundred folds worth of answers and I can
get a distribution out of this so rather
than having a for loop doing this many
times repeated k-fold does that falling
for you internally and then you get lots
of scores back and you can make a
distribution you can think well okay
this is it's you know it might be better
it might be worse I don't know I haven't
changed my my exceeding it to make this
comparable to the previous result but
I've got scores from 76% up to nearly
90% that's way better than I have before
and then if we draw them side-by-side we
can see that we've got two distributions
the left-hand one is the dummy
classifier the best result from the
dummy classifier is worse than the worst
result from the random forests so these
distributions are clearly separate all
of these answers are better than all of
those answers regardless of these split
in the data that we had so we can be
fairly happy that this is a better
classifier at this point we can start
hyper pram for tuning and twiddling
around with different algorithms and
trying lots of things and trying to make
them mean slightly better than the
previous mean and that's the way you've
been a cackle competition but if you
start drawing those distributions of the
new classifier is over the old
distributions
might well start to find they all just
kind of look the same and then within
the variance of well within the bounds
of the variant the natural variants and
noise in those splits and in the models
they're actually this is distributions
are the same thing so these models we
are making with these slightly higher
mean values aren't really any better
than any they're not really
differentiable from any of the others so
I always recommend just drawing the
results of all different experiments and
when you got says hey this is not
getting any better just stop and don't
worry about it don't obsess over hi
perform the tuning on the mic you don't
tend to get very far who's used the
yellow-brick module okay again only a
couple of hands right another great tool
for you
and so yellow-brick this was introduced
at least as I understand it and the PI
dat instructor II video was at London a
couple of years ago and that's when I
learned about it Rachel Brooke I think
yellow-brick takes a bunch of the
example code on the scikit-learn website
for how to visualize your model answers
and makes a really simple couple of line
interface so that you can easily
visualize your circular answers so it's
just a glorified wrapper for a bunch of
examples that come off of the cyclone
website and then more has been added
over time confusion matrix is a great
way to diagnose the quality of your
classify outputs so we can see our true
negatives in the top left hand corner
this is off the random forest classifier
true positives in the bottom right
corner and then we can see the errors
that have been made there aren't so many
errors that are being made here and then
a typical way to proceed is to think
about this tweak your model parameters
and then see if you can shift the error
numbers into their correct quadrants
move them around so you have more truth
and less error and of course you can't
fix all of it because these classes
typically and never fully different not
differentiable what's the word I'm
looking for
separable thank you that's the word I'm
looking for and they're not fully
separable so there will always be some
level of error in there and the areas of
area between the type of model they're
using so this is a way of looking at
errors in your your data it's not really
insightful doesn't get you very far so
one thing I've started to mess around
with is the my visualization take the
same
splits of the data but rather than just
counting the number of true negatives
and true positives that we had instead
drawing the underlying probabilities
that come out of the classifier if a lot
of your probabilities for your true
negatives are over towards zero so they
the classifiers pretty darned confident
that this person really didn't survive
their probability of death if survival
is very low and here if their
probability of survival is very high
then I'm pretty happy that the
classifier is very confident in its
decision making if it were the case that
all of these counts were up towards
let's say 45% so it's this person
definitely died with a forty five
percent likelihood also a fifty five
percent likelihood that they died and if
the true positives were close to say
fifty five percent just over the
decision boundary although the the
binary decision that we see in the
confusion matrix is true the actual my
confidence in the classifiers decision
would be pretty low so this gives me
another way of beginning to dig into the
the probabilities behind things
yellow-brick let's just look at the ROC
curve as well and I was a bit conflicted
about putting this in here ROC curve
comes up in all the tutorials you must
draw a ROC curve to show off the area
under the curve and then you compare the
ROC curve here for this is the random
forests and that's for there gistic
regression that I ran and sure enough
the the AUC is a bit lower eighty-seven
percent here than ninety percent for the
random forests I'm sure what you get out
of ROC curve visualization it's a bit of
a pain to do it given the code on the
cyclone website yellow brick makes it
really easy so I thought it was worth
including if anyone here has actually
made hard decisions using an ROC curve
I'd be very keen to hear about that
afterwards put up your hand in fact if
you find really strong value in an ROC
curve as a diagnostic tool it's in all
the books didn't all them all the
tutorials okay right yeah so precision
recall curves are also in yellow brick
um I put this up just because it's kind
of covered everywhere but then I just
thought what why what what value do I
get out of this so if anyone has
feedback for me afterwards I would love
to hear it I'm not sure about that
conventional wisdom okay so
now I want to stop really drilling down
into what my my estimator is doing so
one of the ways that I start to do that
is I take the underlying probabilities
so the truth eval use only the
probabilities from the classify and
compare them to the truth eval use and I
calculate errors I want to see
particularly which thing is it's miss
predicting the most so when it should
predict zero but it predicts one so
maybe it predicts 99% so I'd be a 99%
error now when it should predict two one
and it predicts close to a zero so I
want those largest magnitude errors so
you can calculate your errors and then
sort a data frame by size of error and
in this case I filtered for people who
did survive and then it predicted that
they died so there was a very large
error and I get the underlying
probability from the estimator and I've
got the passenger ID at which point I
can match that data back against the
original data that goes into the
learning process and here I've used the
pandas style function to put some colors
behind this so we can see those same
passenger IDs coming through we can see
that his female is false so all of these
all of these people who were miss
predicted were male from the passenger
manifest their siblings spouses parents
and children count to the size of their
family is very low typically zero the
fares are very low as well they've got a
mixture of ages but in this case all of
them should have survived but they were
predicted to all have died so I can't
diagnose anything from this particularly
I don't think because this data right
the underlying things are here I trust
when I do this on a client problem
typically all the misc coding is in the
date so just jump straight out and I can
see numbers that are strings or dates
that are back to front or things that
are misrepresented things that are
clearly coded wrong all of it jumps out
in in this display so this is a
brilliant first way you build a model
you do a little diagnostic all the
rubbish just leaps into your face that's
kind of nice because then you've got a
way to go through and begin to fix the
underlying rubbish you could then split
your errors by some kind of significant
feature so if I've looked at say feature
importance or permutation importance
behind my estimator and it tells me Oh P
class the weather there first
sir class is an incredibly predictive
feature I think okay right so what if I
split out all of the in the test set
split out all of the first-class
passengers and then compute some
accuracy metrics around only first-class
passengers and what if I do the same for
second-class passengers so we get some
Precision's recalls and F ones that are
pretty good for the first-class
passengers this is on the test set we've
trained on first second and third class
the whole data set then on the test set
we've split out just the first class and
the computing these metrics just from
the first class that's pretty good take
just the second-class passengers out and
those results are better so for some
reason second-class passengers with
respect to this data and this estimator
are easier to predict now that might be
the estimator is somehow better at this
data set might be the data is cleaner
for second-class passengers it might
just be that second-class passengers
were easier to separate in this data set
it was more likely you could figure out
if they were going to survive or going
to die but this gives you another way of
diagnosing your data if you're not
convinced by the way you split your data
rounds and which bits the model says
they're easier to predict and which bits
are hard to predict you might want to go
back to your data or revisit your
understanding of the problem to think
about whether you really trust these
results here's a crazy idea I've been
developing recently and you might tell
me it's bonkers that'd be great feedback
you might tell me it's useful tell me
afterwards and give me your thoughts one
thing I've been curious about is if I
start splitting my data out by a major
feature like p class or the sex of the
passenger I'm imposing a constraint upon
the data I'm saying I think these things
distinguish things that we can predict
and these things that we eat can't
predict and where the errors might lies
I'm imposing my own knowledge upon the
problem what I really want is the data
to bubble up in some kind of
unsupervised magic way which bits of the
data I should be paying attention to so
I've developed this as a first idea it
could be stupid but you tell me and if I
use tease me a dimensionality reduction
technique that is built into
scikit-learn I can group all of the
passengers that are similar by features
so I'm not grouping by the survived
column I don't want to put the target
variable into this set but for all of
the other features that go into the
machine learning the thing that you
learn the the relationship from the X
values I put those into teeth snare
it projects this high dimensional
continuous and categorical feature space
down to a two-dimensional plot so many
dots that are close to each other are
passengers whose attributes look similar
that's that's it
and if they're a long way from each
other then those attributes look quite
different from each other
according to TC I've then drawn it with
crosses if they didn't survive and
circles if they did survive so I've
taken that extra column that I wasn't
using in TC and used it to to enhance
the diagram so I didn't go into TC that
was used to enhance I think color by
absolute error so we look at the things
that predicts correctly and things it
predicts wrongly if absolute error is
small and it's a cross then the person
did die and the model predicted that
accurately to the Arabs small if the
absolute error is high so close to white
and it's a circle then the person did
survive but the model predicted that
they did die very confident the error
was large and then we get some
interesting patterns popping out so we
got a bunch of dark crosses here so
these all kind of look fairly consistent
most people died and the model said they
did die correctly and then we get some
areas where you get a mixture of crosses
in red so this is people who died and
the model got it correct and circles
that are bright so this is where people
did survive but the model said they
didn't survive so what if we then start
to look at the passengers represented by
these coordinates in the T stay to get
back to the underlying features then the
model is telling me in this unsupervised
way which things look like they they
look similar and we've got these
conflicted areas in the decision space
so if I pull out the things that look
similar where the predictions were all
good we see they're all third-class
passengers they're typically all-male
they've got small families they didn't
pay a lot what's funny about the age
imputed column now I don't know if
that's a thing you know these that
didn't seem to influence the decision
all of these predictions all but one of
them are correct so you did a great job
maybe this age in pewter doesn't really
matter here but it's a little bit
suspicious to me that when I pull out a
region of space that the model says it
looks kind of similar and I find it's
full of people have got the same imputed
values the same missing missing column
that's kind of weird maybe I want to dig
for
and see if I really trust the data
behind that and if we look at a
conflicted area this is that second
region of space I find lots of
first-class passengers it's female it's
false so they're male small families age
imputed is also pretty pretty much full
of 28 and if you pull out if you go back
to the source of truth from the Titanic
manifest you see that these ages are all
over the place and if you put in the
truth ages and make a reproduction you
get a very different prediction than the
one that we get here which suggests that
if you were to fill in this data that's
missing you could get a better result
perhaps so I think that's kind of an
interesting diagnostic technique you
might tell me it's not so I'm curious
about your feedback afterwards and then
finally a couple of slides I'll just
wrap up who's used Shaklee explanations
before the Shapley tool I don't come
across that it's pretty new presented at
nips a year or so back it's one of a set
of explanation tools that have been
developed recently ten minutes until I
need to be off stage okay it's fine yeah
I'm at five minutes that's great I'm all
good so Shapley is one of three
techniques for explaining your models to
other techniques
Eli five and lime and they're being
covered in a talk tomorrow
so Shapley as the paper presents itself
is a game theoretic optimal solution to
the other two approaches which gives you
everything it's the one explanation
techniques that rules them all
apparently I'm not quite sure I believe
that yet but it does feel the more
powerful than the other two approaches
and for continuous space problems so but
it's happily explanation I could do
several things I'm going to show you
three of them I'm going to show here the
four things it can do if I take a single
prediction that I want to explain so
passenger ID 231 the truth is one so
this person survived I can look at the
underlying features just from my data
and then the question is well how do
these features contribute to the
prediction for this person survived and
then the Shapley explanation this is a
nice bit of d3 javascript in the browser
we can get the numbers out says well it
was roughly the case that 40% of people
survived
because this person had a fare of
eighty-three which is pretty high that
had a significant increase in their
probability of survival because their
first class that had a bigger increase
in their probability of survival and
because they were female it had an even
bigger increase in their probability of
survival and when you sum those bits
together you get a number that's one so
ninety-nine point seven percent get a
hundred percent probability of survival
given these particular attributes so
this is a way of explaining given all of
the other examples that are around that
it's based on a model based on all of
the the test set data that's available
explaining individual predictions if we
put in a different example passenger ID
635 true to 0 they died the model says
they died so the model is an agreement
which is brilliance is my random forest
model these are the attributes if we put
those into Shapley it gives us a
slightly different display it's saying
we're about 60% of people died given
that the fact that they had a larger
than usual fare decreases their
probability of death the fact that they
varied decreases their probability of
survival the fact they were third-class
decreases their probability of survival
even more the fact they had a larger
family decreases their probability of
survival even more but because they were
very young age was 9 and because they
were female so they weren't a man or
woman that increases their chance of
survival and if you sum all of those
bits together you get an explanation of
0.06 which is very close to this
explanation here so you can then start
to pull out the underlying features that
drive the decision now you might not
like those decisions you might sit back
and go with that out of rubbish what's
coming on there that makes no sense then
you have to ask yourself well is the
model overfitting is my data straight is
my understanding of the underlying
problem good so I'm using this in the
insurance industry as we try to explain
the predictions behind some of the
riskiness of certain assets and then how
you price those particular policies and
this means that I can take my incredibly
rich black box model which gives a great
result and none of us really understand
how it works because hey you've got a
thousand 3xg boost model with a thousand
wide feature set what the heck's going
on in there but I can break out the most
important contributors to the final
regressed this ish
and he worked for regression as well and
then explain what those contributions
are on the business so he goes oh yeah
that kind of makes sense that makes
sense yeah I kind of liked that story
and that's nice
or when the data's gough then they turn
around to go that doesn't make any sense
that I'm thinking it's because I can see
the date that's break and those numbers
shouldn't make any sense at all so I
find this very useful as a diagnostic
Shapley also groups together all of the
similar predictions by similar features
so this is not a million miles away from
that teeny diagram I showed here
examples thirty-four is the one that I
showed on the previous slide so a first
class woman and who paid a fair amount
of money and got a 97 percent on 99.7%
prediction if I look at the next example
along number 36 very similar attributes
but a different camp for the family's
lies and a slightly lower probability of
survival as a result so you can start to
scroll back it's a nice interactive
interface you just scroll back and forth
you can see people who it predicted
survived or died and see what the
contributions of all the individual
features were and a final thing that it
can do if you take all of the examples
in your test set and then you start
saying well what contribution does the
is female indicator have if everything
else is held constant so what which
which features kind of feel predictive
and what in what way are they predictive
its female if it's true it's a 1 and if
it's false it's a 0 so it's a high that
means each of these dots was a row and
his female was true in this case or
false in that case with respect to the
shap values increasing means better
chance of survival so if is female is
true I think all the records say that if
is female is true then there's an
increased chance of survival and
sometimes quite a high increased chance
of survival and if it's female is false
then most of the what all the examples
give a smaller contribution to chance of
survival decreasing so if you're a male
there's a good chance that you will be
less likely to survive unless some other
feature increases your survival rate P
class has a similar result if P Class E
low-low is blue lowest one if your first
class you have an increased chance of
survival if P class is high third class
that means you're going steerage down
below you have a decreased chance of
survival but a lot of it clustered
around the zero points or not having a
huge impact whereas it's FEMA has this
massive impact across the board
age imputed a lot of clustering around
the center but if your age imputed your
age is very low like the nine year old
child typically there's a much higher
chance of survival so that's kind of
interesting um siblings spouses parents
and children almost all the results are
clustered around the zero point but if
you had high count of sibling spouses
parents and children then your chance of
survival decreases so that's a lopsided
contribution to whether you survive or
die so and there's a there are some
further pots that chap he brings out its
very youngest all it does work you need
to use the get master version the
published version on pip is a bit busted
in notebooks definitely recommend you
give it a go the documentation is a bit
light but I think the results are really
interesting and Tobias tomorrow is
talking on Eli five and lime so if
you're interested in this I suggested
following up on that talk so closing I
think everyone should be diagnosing
their machine learning just like they do
bug their code particularly if you can't
explain the working of your machine
learning model to a colleague
particularly a non-technical colleague
then I believe that we don't understand
what this model does and black boxes are
cool for winning cattle competitions
they're not called for having robust
reliable engineered solutions in the
workplace that we need to keep
maintained after we've gone so we have
to be able to debug and understand these
things and these tools begin to let us
do that
I give training and coaching on this
kind of stuff that's interesting talk to
me
there'll be a write-up on this on my on
my blog there's a write-up from Pilate
in London from a month ago and I'll be
posting the the code up on to data
science delivered on github shortly I
love talking about this you can buy me
beer if you want boy I just love talking
about this stuff but do buy a beer or a
coffee for the fellow volunteers here
please but I do have a request for you a
very serious request and I realized that
after seven years talking about a year
realize this I've never asked for
anything back in return and it turns out
I like receiving postcards so I now have
a small collection of postcards up in my
office
that remind me that when I volunteer and
put time in people like this stuff and
then I get a postcard sent to me from an
interesting place on the planet so if
you if you've learned something and you
want to send me a postcard of the future
I'd be super happy just send me an email
I'll send you my dress I'm your postcard
okay we're not we're from I just like
receive in postcards it makes me happy
so please do that um
and that'll be it thank you very much so
in terms of paying for coffee and beer
to people that you appreciate I just
want to announce that indeed the beer
tonight is free so we are now between
this moment and coffee I think there
should be at least one or two questions
that you know are relevant to the entire
crowd before we have coffee does anyone
have a question I'll take just two
questions and then we can have coffee
because I think morning coffee is
important thank you it was a really
great presentation so my question is
about the first part of your
presentation do you have any suggestions
for a baseline classifier for problems
with heavily imbalanced classes so it's
a game to have a solution for problems
of it's imbalanced classes for I'm gonna
guess it depends on which part of the
early part of the talk the ROC curves
are pretty good at diagnosing imbalance
classes pays thankless fires for bait
for designing baseline classifiers a
baseline classifies
sorry baseline classifies so no you can
one is one of there are several
strengths there are five strategies in
the dummy classifier one is stratified
sampling so it tries to reflect the
underlying prior knowledge I mean with
heavily in balanced classes everything
you just predict
yeah exactly it's Leeds yeah it's I
don't mean you still think you have to
do it probably I would start with say a
most frequent just because I get a
baseline that I shouldn't be any worse
than this but yeah that's that's a
harder one I've had to talk afterwards
about that perhaps if you give me some
more context about it I think partly
this advice is I try to keep this advice
general and each time I dive off into a
special problem I realized that all my
general advice is a bit guff and I have
to think again about an underlying
problem and how I represent the right
way to start process but thinking about
a baseline and building up is the
important bit I guess but sorry I kind
of a clear answer their other problem
thanks for the talk is fun um I had a
question I actually don't know much
about the dataset you just have to
predict alive or dead sorry I did kind
of assume everyone knows the titanic
dataset yeah you've got a thousand
passengers and Titanic sinks some people
survived some people died can you use
their attributes to predict who will
survive or die and women and children
typically survived rich people had a
much better chance of surviving poor men
who were middle aged or younger
typically died and that's kind of the
end result and the Titanic film shows
you that and then the question it's kind
of used the data to make a similar
prediction you only need scikit-learn
you don't need to lean out of the copy
others we still have over 20 minutes to
get a coffee so let's just do one more
round of applause Ian thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]